bienvenidos a este especial informativo
en france 24 propósito de las elecciones
generales en ecuador este país andino se
convirtió en el primero de américa
latina en realizar elecciones
presidenciales en medio de la pandemia
de kobe 19 más de 13 millones de
ciudadanos de una población total de
17,8 millones estaban llamados a las
urnas para elegir presidente y
vicepresidente para el periodo 2021 2025
y además a 137 integrantes de la
asamblea nacional y cinco miembros del
parlamento andino las urnas abrieron a
las siete de la mañana y salvaron a las
cinco de la tarde hora de quito las
votaciones se llevaron a cabo en medio
de fuertes medidas de bioseguridad en un
intento por evitar nuevos contagios de
kobe 19 en un país que cuenta con más de
35 mil casos activos a la fecha y más de
15 mil muertos a causa de la enfermedad
el consejo nacional electoral ya comenzó
a entregar los primeros resultados de la
jornada revisemos entonces cómo se como
aparecen los diferentes candidatos los
tres más opcionados cuando han pasado
apenas dos horas del cierre de las urnas
tenemos en primer lugar andrés árabes
que registra un 30 77 por ciento de la
votación seguido de guillermo un lazo
con un 16,75 por ciento y en tercer
lugar aparece ya q pérez con un 24 31
por ciento teniendo en cuenta que apenas
tenemos un 0,3 por ciento de las mesas
escrutadas por supuesto esto es apenas
una primera tendencia de lo que puede
ser el resultado final de esta elección
presidencial en ecuador la primera de
este año en américa latina' esta jornada
electoral transcurrió tranquila y
prácticamente sin incidentes veamos un
resumen del día en este informe
preparado por nuestro periodista álvaro
cordero
entre una alta participación e
incertidumbre por la pandemia millones
de ecuatorianos salieron a votar a su
futuro presidente y vice presidente
desde las primeras horas los principales
candidatos se acercaron a los centros de
votación y comentaron sus sensaciones
20 muy motivados muy motivados invitar a
todos los ecuatorianos a participar en
esta jornada democrática es un día de
fiesta un día de unidad nacional un día
de esperanza por fin una vuelta me veré
con clientes y el pueblo ecuatoriano en
el 11 de abril próximo
la victoria será contundente a favor
vuelvo a ver pero si algo preocupa hoy a
los ecuatorianos más que botar el
alcohol 19 a pesar de las medidas de
seguridad las largas filas de personas
han hecho temer a los votantes por un
contagio masivo en los próximos días
esto aplicado ya que las filas están muy
largas
hay que esperar bastante tiempo y
ahorita con el tema de la pandemia todos
estamos asustados protegidos al máximo e
intentando respetar la distancia de
seguridad
los ecuatorianos salieron a las calles
dispuestos a cumplir con el voto
obligatorio y a decidir por el futuro de
su país
estos comicios contaron con una cifra
récord de 16 candidatos entre los cuales
destacan andrés arados del partido unión
por la esperanza guillermo lazo del
movimiento creo y ya q pérez del partido
indígena pachakutik sin embargo los
sondeos apuntan a que ninguno de los
tres aspirantes de esos tres alcanzaría
la votación necesaria para definir la
contienda en primera vuelta y se
realizaría una segunda en el mes de
abril ampliamos esta información con
nuestro corresponsal en quito- gustavo
ortega quien ha estado atento a las
principales noticias del día ha gustado
cuéntenos para empezar cómo transcurrió
la jornada en medio de las filas y las
medidas para evitar nuevos contagios por
kobe 19
sí porque las jornadas ha transcurrido
en total calma en la realización de
estos comicios electorales en ecuador ha
sido una característica las grandes
filas en los centros de votación hubo
preocupación porque el aislamiento y el
proceso de manera muy lenta era la
principal preocupación que tenían los
ecuatorianos habían algunos centros que
estaban muy llenos al 10 40 donde la
presencia de votantes era masiva pero el
ingreso era muy lento había centros
donde había
una participación muy desarrollada era
muy fácil ingresar ejercer el voto y
salir por el cual se desarrolló con
total calma esta realización del proceso
comicial la única preocupación realmente
era hacerlo rápido evitar el
aglomeramiento de las nominaciones para
poder ejercer el derecho electoral y
sobre todo aplicar la multa para poderse
es retirarnos más rápido posible si
gusta o también en cuéntenos el
candidato a rauch ya se declaró ganador
explíquenos gustavo que representan esos
resultados a boca de urna quien los hace
y en qué momento se espera tener
resultados oficiales
tales como tú dices el candidato andrés
sagrados se ha adjudicado en la victoria
hace un par de minutos el inclusive a
través de la cuenta en la red social
'twitter' aseguraba que había duplicado
sus resultados a favor pero a pesar de
que esto no es oficial los resultados no
darían para hacerse con una primera
vuelta electoral una victoria sin la
necesidad de realizar una segunda vuelta
electoral poco a poco el consejo
nacional electoral ya empieza a
proyectar los resultados por las
distintas provincias del país pero llama
mucho la atención que incide
aparentemente una segunda vuelta que se
realizaría con la culpa de sino con
guillermo o el lazo quien ha quedado muy
por debajo según los resultados que
empiezan a aparecer la boca de urna e
inclusive los datos oficiales que están
apareciendo desde este centro de cómputo
de dispuesto por el consejo nacional
electoral es un proceso de escrutinio
que está realizando el órgano comicial
pero ya empezamos a ver los distintos
resultados tanto por provincias por
asambleísta
el binomio presidencia pues gustado
justamente estamos hablando de andrés
araus quien es el candidato apadrinado
por el ex presidente rafael correa un
hombre de 36 años que podría entonces
convertirse en uno de los opcionados
para la segunda vuelta veamos un poco
más de este candidato
pero del 2001
[Aplausos]
nosotros es el candidato a la
presidencia de ecuador andrés arauz y
así se define él mismo en su biografía
de 'twitter' patriota demócrata
progresista candidato a la presidencia
del ecuador nunca me niego a un ceviche
jipijapa junto con su candidato
vicepresidencial carlos rabascall forman
el llamado binomio de la esperanza
además están apadrinados por el ex
presidente rafael correa al que arauz
lleva en los mítines en un cartón a
tamaño real
de hecho durante la presidencia de
correa fue ministro entre 2015 y 2017 de
conocimiento y talento humano y durante
unos meses ministro de cultura ahora
pese a su juventud a los 36 años podría
convertirse en el presidente más joven
de la historia de ecuador
[Música]
nacido en quitó habla inglés francés y
ruso y es graduado en economía por la
universidad de michigan define sus
políticas como post keynesianas sociales
y solidarias su objetivo recuperar el
progresismo de la presidencia de rafael
correa una meta que le ha llevado al
consejo ejecutivo de la internacional
progresista donde participan figuras
como el senador demócrata bernie sanders
el ex ministro de finanzas griego yannis
varoufakis o el vicepresidente del
gobierno español pablo iglesias uno
ingleses fuera de serie ahí está su
currículum y creo que va a ser un gran
presidente del web
tras el anuncio de su candidatura muchos
se preguntaban quién era el respondía
que el perfecto desconocido
una pandemia con la campaña virtualizada
se presenta mediante una canción en
redes sociales hablamos ahora del
conservador guillermo lazo quien es otro
de los principales aspirantes en estas
elecciones en ecuador con una extensa
trayectoria como banquero lazos se
presenta como un candidato por tercera
vez consecutiva al primer cargo del país
crítico del correísmo defiende la
inversión extranjera en sectores clave
como el petróleo o el de las
telecomunicaciones además plantea una
lucha contra la corrupción de la mano de
las naciones unidas y la organización de
estados américanos veamos este informe
one pupiales
lo que más representa a guillermo lasso
es quizás su mayor lastre en su carrera
política fue durante casi 20 años
presidente del banco de guayaquil llegó
a la política en 1998 como gobernador de
la provincia de guayas y al año
siguiente se convirtió en el ministro de
economía
y eran años de crisis en ecuador había
una contracción del crédito y una falta
de liquidez en el sistema financiero que
ocasionó que la mayoría de sus clientes
perdiera una parte de sus ahorros era
una nación hundida en el desempleo y la
inflación que terminó llevando al país a
adoptar el dólar como moneda oficial
en 2013 se presentó a las elecciones
pero perdió ante el entonces presidente
rafael correa que fue reelegido con más
del doble de votos que el antiguo
banquero en 2017 volvió esta vez para
medirse ante lenin moreno en segunda
vuelta moreno entonces candidato de
correa menciona unos comicios en donde
se realizó un recuento parcial de votos
tras denuncias de fraude por parte de la
zona ahora vuelve definiendo un perfil
aperturista que se refleja en sus
propuestas económicas para hacer frente
al desempleo ya la pobreza buscó
solucionar el problema de empleo
promoviendo inversión inversión privada
local internacional en sectores
estratégicos de la economía ecuatoriana
del sector público en el sector
petrolero en el sector eléctrico en el
sector de las telecomunicaciones
tratando de que llegan al ecuador
empresas con buenas prácticas
corporativas del mundo occidental
es precisamente ese sector uno de los
mayores desafíos del gobierno entrante
tras un mandato que la economía no
despegó y en el que el rechazo a las
reformas propuestas por el fondo
monetario internacional generaron unas
protestas nunca antes vistas en los
últimos años
de los 16 candidatos que aspiran a la
presidencia de ecuador el tercero que
repunta según las encuestas es ya q
pérez el primer aspirante indígena en 15
años el se ha caracterizado por una
campaña hecha en bicicleta una bicicleta
de bambú por los pueblos principalmente
indígenas de ecuador y por una agenda
basada en la prioridad del medio
ambiente veamos un poco más de
superficie
rodó por el país con una bicicleta de
bambú él es ya cooper es candidato por
el movimiento indígena pachakutik es el
único aspirante por los pueblos nativos
el abogado de 51 años tiene cuatro
maestrías y centra su propuesta en la
defensa del medio ambiente cuando fue en
pandemia él hizo algo que la gente jamás
se animó paulo el cuerpo y por eso mismo
ahora tiene mi apoyo y tiene por mí mi
voz
ya q pérez cultivó su capital político
durante las protestas de octubre de 2019
que iniciaron en rechazo a las medidas
económicas del actual presidente
lenin moreno sabemos que hay algo pérez
nunca fue un líder histórico ni surgido
del movimiento indígena por lo tanto
hay que ver en el futuro pero también
podría ser un topo para el movimiento
indígena porque finalmente lo que está
representando no es el proyecto
histórico del movimiento indígena de la
conaie está representando un proyecto
personal y un proyecto que tiene muchos
vínculos con la derecha en ecuador el 7
por ciento de la población es indígena y
si no llega a segunda vuelta una alianza
con algunos de los candidatos podría
inclinar la intención de voto a pérez se
le relaciona con la derecha si queremos
ser el ecuador igual que venezuela estar
gobernado
a un presidente que va a ser igual que
maduro
que no va a tener una brújula que no va
a tener un horizonte que nos va a llevar
a una crisis insostenible que nos va a
acabar con la dolarización en 2017 pérez
ya dio su apoyo al candidato de derecha
y erbol aso pero recientemente se ha
desvinculado de él confiado en que
llegará segunda vuelta se niega a
anunciar a quien dará su apoyo queda por
ver si el activista podrá capitalizar el
cansancio de los ciudadanos en los
partidos tradicionales y convertirse en
el primer mandatario indígena del
ecuador pues acabamos de ver los
perfiles de tres de los principales
candidatos a las elecciones en ecuador
las elecciones presidenciales de una
lista de 16 en total de los cuales
solamente se destaca una mujer jimena
peña del partido alianza país pues
justamente el de presidente o el próximo
presidente de ecuador tendrá que
enfrentar retos bastante difíciles
porque el país enfrenta por un lado la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 por otro lado la
crisis económica ocasionada por esta
misma pandemia y un momento de
polarización política muy muy fuerte
para quien vaya a liderar el país
adelante vamos a volver con nuestro
corresponsal en quito- gustavo ortega
para hablar un poco acerca de cómo hacer
este nuevo período en la presidencia del
ecuador gustavo usted no se escucha en
este momento se encuentra en un centro
de cómputo con información de primera
mano de los primeros resultados de esta
jornada desde su punto de vista usted
que vive el día a día en ecuador cuál
será el principal reto de cada la
ciudadanía y de cara a las instituciones
para el próximo presidente
pero antes de darte mi apreciación sobre
cuál será el próximo reto quiero
informarte que continúan los resultados
electorales y llaman la atención como
inclusive en la provincia del guayas el
propio candidato guillermo lazos de
donde es procedente no ha ganado
inclusive está muy por debajo de andrés
araujo aquí nos superan
sobre el 44% de los resultados y sucede
lo contrario en todo caso en la
provincia de pichincha donde es el
candidato andrés ganando en este momento
guillermo lasso pero a pesar de todo la
diferencia no es muy alta entre ambos
candidatos pues me preguntabas al
respecto de cuál será el propio cómo
será el próximo gobierno del próximo
presidente en principio hay que
recuperar mucho la economía de generar
muchos empleos en este momento ya el
ciudadano ecuatoriano no soporta un
nuevo confinamiento ha sido la
preocupación constante durante los 10
meses de pandemia sobre todo por la
paralización de actividades la
paralización de los ciudadanos que
trabajan el día a día los comerciantes
los vendedores de hortalizas
transportistas los taxistas siempre han
manifestado como la adivinación de su
trabajo ha venido disminuyendo también
de sus ingresos recordemos que según los
especialistas en los trabajadores han
definido el 40 por ciento de sus
ingresos por el cual el próximo
mandatario tendrá que preocuparse por
crear algún tipo de mecanismos hay
algunas propuestas que hablan sobre
apoyos económicos como bonos de
emergencia y otras propuestas que hablan
sobre reducción tributaria o sobre otras
propuestas que hablan sobre la
flexibilización y sobre la creación de
diferentes tipos de contratación todo
para beneficiar estimular el empleo y
que los ciudadanos vuelvan de nuevo a la
actividad comercial
bueno pues gustavo hace apenas dos horas
y 15 minutos cerraron las urnas en todo
el país en ecuador así que lo que hay de
resultados es apenas un pequeño esbozo
menos del 0,5 por ciento apenas está
contabilizando así que explorar los
resultados son muy preliminares para
estar los tres candidatos más opcionados
que ya se preveían de color las
encuestas liderando esta intención de
voto y estado
efectiva durante la jornada de hoy y el
ganador tendrá que enfrentar como ya
hablábamos gustado retos importantes
veamos un informe al respecto
el mandato de lenin moreno es un buen
ejemplo el próximo presidente de ecuador
no lo va a tener fácil en primer lugar
tendrá que lidiar con una sociedad
polarizada y un debate público centrado
en dos palabras constantes correa y
venezuela hugo por un andrew zarautz
candidato apadrinado por el ex
presidente ecuatoriano genera esperanzas
en sectores de la población que rechazan
la austeridad y reivindican un mayor
papel social del estado
del otro lado detractores de rafael
correa consideran que volver al
socialismo llevaría al país a
convertirse en venezuela este debate no
se puede entender sin la maltrecha
economía ecuatoriana desde 2015 el país
vive la desaceleración económica por la
caída de los precios del petróleo una
dependencia a la que se le suma a una
pandemia que deja 600.000 desempleados
una economía contraída entre un 10 y un
12 por ciento una deuda que equivale al
60 por ciento del producto interior
bruto y una tasa de pobreza en torno al
35 por ciento
el nuevo presidente además se encontrará
con una reestructuración del pago de la
deuda de 17
millones de dólares sin embargo tendrá
que decidir si acepta las contundentes
exigencias de austeridad del fondo
monetario internacional o si decide
enfrentarlas
pero en lo que sigue coinciden todos es
en la necesidad de empezar una campaña
de vacunación que vuelva a poner en
marcha la economía en un sistema de
salud precario que se vio superado en la
primera ola de kobe 19 en guayaquil
segunda ciudad de ecuador el nuevo
presidente también tendrá que lidiar con
un organizado movimiento indígena en
2019 ya demostró a lenin moreno su
capacidad para paralizar el país por
último la elección será clave en un
plano internacional
una victoria de arauz acercaría a
ecuador a bolivia argentina y podría
reactivar unasur mientras que también
por otro lado podría debilitar la
recuperada relación con eeuu
gustavo nuestro corresponsal en ecuador
volvemos con usted porque es importante
que hablemos de una coyuntura muy
importante que enfrenta ecuador en este
momento igual que el resto de los países
del planeta y es la pandemia de ccoo y
19 ecuador fue un país que al principio
de la pandemia sobre los meses de marzo
de abril de 2020 mostró imágenes muy
fuertes principalmente en la ciudad de
guayaquil donde se veía la escasez de
ataúd de la escasez de atención
hospitalaria para una población que
estaba muy afectada por el virus que en
este momento eso ha desaparecido pero
que de todas maneras tiene ya más de 35
mil casos activos en este momento y más
de 15.000 muertos cuéntenos cómo ha
afectado la pandemia de coi 19 la
intención de voto en ecuador como los
candidatos han jugado con la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 país sus diferentes campañas
para traer para tratar de atraer
entonces la votación de los ciudadanos
en el acceso a la vacuna ha sido una de
las propuestas que se ha politizado en
cuanto a este manejo de la campaña
electoral todos han ofrecido vacunas
todos han ofrecido reestructurar el
sistema de salud todos han ofrecido
mejorar el sistema de seguridad social
unos han hablado inclusive sobre la
telemedicina inclusive el candidato del
lazo quien su binomio es médico también
ofrecía información sobre su propuesta
de mejorar el sistema de salud también
el candidato paúl carrasco por lo menos
hablaba sobre generar una telemedicina
un sistema moderno de atención médica y
así sucesivamente todos han hablado
sobre la mejoría del servicio de salud
todo esto también hay que tomar en
cuenta que ecuador ha estado
caracterizado por muchos casos de
corrupción para la adquisición de
implementos médicos ha sido la
característica durante este manejo de la
pandemia en la compra de accesorios
compra de mascarilla compra de
fundas para cuerpos ha sido la principal
característica de igual forma también el
acceso a las vacunas cuántas vacunas
accedieron el principio se había dicho
y vamos a acceder en un aproximado de
86 mil dosis la primera envío
posteriormente se informó que solamente
llegaron 8 mil dosis al país y se había
dicho inclusive que iban a llegar 15 mil
dosis semanales todo esto se anunció con
bombos y platillos se llevaron a todos
los medios de comunicación a hacer esta
cobertura de la llegada de las primeras
vacunas que generó esperanza como yo por
supuesto todo el mundo quiere vacunarse
todo el mundo lo ve como una esperanza
para ir a la normalidad económica y
sentirse protegido pero la realidad es
que no han llegado a las 12 suficientes
no se conoce es decir una estrategia de
vacunación y el ejecutivo nacional
también ha recibido muchas quejas muchas
denuncias sobre el trato de la
vacunación pudimos conocer de manera
internacional como el propio ministro de
salud fue acusado por abuso de poder por
desviar a las vacunas se le había dicho
que primero se iban a vacunar los
trabajadores en primera línea cuando fue
él quien se vacunó primero primero se
iban a curar los trabajadores de la
salud los trabajadores
los desechos sólidos los militares y
policías pero inclusive de las vacunas
para vacunar primero a sus familiares en
un centro de atención al privado
así que también ha recibido el reclamo
por el manejo de los contratos públicos
garantizados en la ley de apoyo
humanitario a los médicos y post grad y
estás han reclamado continuamente y han
prospectado han salido a las calles con
muchos inclusive han tenido que
renunciar mucho inclusive de reclamos
que no han tenido contratos laborales
para lo que ha sido una garantía por
parte del ejecutivo nacional que en los
últimos días también anunció la entrega
de bonos de 200 dólares para ayudarlos
económicamente así que el trato de la
vacuna el trato de los crecimientos
médicos ha sido un tema que se ha
politizado en el país preguntado a
ecuador es una de las 10 naciones del
continente americano que ya inició con
la vacunación por supuesto cuando los
obstáculos que usted nos está
presentando en este reporte y vamos a
pasar ahora al análisis aquí en plan 24
tenemos análisis en profundidad y
tenemos dos invitadas desde ecuador para
analizar esta jornada electoral por un
lado tenemos
a maría dolores niño ella es abogada
docente de la universidad internacional
de ecuador y directora del observatorio
de derecho y justicia bienvenida maría
dolores a france24 por otro lado tenemos
a angélica bat politóloga docente de la
universidad de cuenca y quiero
justamente iniciar con angélica esta
primera ronda de análisis para
preguntarle cómo analiza usted el hecho
de que en esta elección haya 16
candidatos una cita récord en el ecuador
y que en la mayoría elecciones de
américa latina no se alcanza una
cantidad una cantidad tal de candidatos
así que que nos muestra esto este esto
que representa en términos de leer la
realidad política del ecuador en este
momento
bueno en primer lugar muchas gracias por
la invitación un saludo a todos los que
están viendo y escuchando para nosotros
también fue una sorpresa ecuador
históricamente había tenido una alta
fragmentación pero nunca habíamos
llegado a tantos digamos a ese volumen
de candidatos que tenemos eso nos
demuestra varias cosas una en primer
lugar es una desintegración del sistema
de partidos o directamente la ausencia
de un sistema de partidos en donde
digamos donde podemos identificar de
manera clara
organizaciones políticas que están ahí
de manera permanente para poder intentar
sacar adelante propuestas estables de
gobierno lo que tenemos en el ecuador
desde hace muchos años con la excepción
de la década de gobierno de rafael
correa y ahora veremos qué pasa después
de una serie de agrupaciones políticas
que se activan de cara a las contiendas
electorales pues más con el fin de
conseguir votos que hay organizaciones
que tengan presencia de manera estable
en él
entre la sociedad entre elecciones y la
otra cara de esa moneda tiene que ver
también no solo con los 16 candidatos
presidenciales que es lo que solemos
hablar sino que también esta
fragmentación se refleja a nivel
provincial con la gran cantidad de
candidatos a legisladores que tenemos y
lo que se puede ver entre unos y otros
son unas agendas un poco bastante vacías
de contenido en donde hay una especie de
banalización diría yo de lo que implica
ejercer el cargo de representación
popular entonces estamos ante escenarios
bastante competitivos pero también muy
inciertos donde hay donde la ciudadanía
en sí misma no se identifica de manera
fuerte directamente con los partidos
políticos y en donde las elecciones son
vistas como oportunidades
más bien de de aprovechar
y diré
el envío un dentro de un proceso
electoral pero realmente los candidatos
con propuestas muy vacías y al final lo
que hemos visto es la concentración del
voto en torno a unos cuatro candidatos
que son curiosamente los que tenían
mayor apoyo en términos de instituciones
y de partidos detrás no
independientemente del análisis de los
resultados o lo que puede implicar para
el correísmo o la ausencia de correísmo
en una segunda vuelta tenemos digamos la
concentración de voto en torno a cuatro
partidos que son cuatro partidos y que
de alguna manera tienen una presencia ya
de larga data en la historia ecuatoriana
la izquierda democrática pachakutik
después el lunes pero lunes representa
al correísmo con lo cual tampoco se le
puede directamente denotar como partido
totalmente nuevo y después creo que ha
sido la principal fuerza de oposición a
la derecha al otro que hemos visto en
estas elecciones y parece interesante es
que la mayor parte del electorado
ecuatoriano se ha decantado por partidos
de
desde el centro hacia la izquierda y en
ese sentido parece que la derecha tiene
un pecho que le es difícil romper un
techo de cristal que le es difícil
superar bueno pues el análisis para
empezar de angélica a bat en cuanto a
porque vimos en esta elección 16
candidatos sin embargo la pregunta
fundamental que se hace en los medios de
comunicación y también por supuesto la
ciudadanía ecuatoriana es si ahora o no
segunda vuelta parece ser que ninguno de
los 16 candidatos ni siquiera los tres
que lideran las encuestas tienen el
poder suficiente de convocatoria para
poder lograr más del 50 por ciento de
los votos o para sacar al menos el 40
con 10 puntos porcentuales de ventaja
sobre el siguiente candidato vamos a
hablar entonces con variables niño para
preguntarle en según su opinión ahora
una segunda vuelta en ecuador tras esta
jornada electoral si habrá una segunda
vuelta quién cree usted vamos a hablar
todavía sin tener resultados definitivos
serán los partícipes de esa segunda
vuelta y el tercero que en este caso
podría ser según los sondeos previos ya
q pérez como inclinaría esa intención de
voto para una segunda vuelta que podría
ser
al momento no se tienen que olvidar los
tratos de sociales le especifique el vio
a las 5 de la tarde que en el momento
cuando se cierran y el suelo disfrutado
del éxito y los resultados del exit
polls arrojan unos números dan cuenta de
la existencia ha sido una segunda vuelta
la posibilidad de segunda vuelta estando
los candidatos para unos que estén
tomando a la izquierda y el candidato
lazo haciendo al derecho en tercer lugar
como soy los decía el candidato ya
cooper es que el representante el
movimiento incluso en el ecuador está
ocupada desde ese lugar y bueno habría
que ver en realidad de cómo los
candidatos que quedan para la segunda
vuelta en cierto no negociar con el
esfuerzo de que los movimientos se
apoyan o pertenecen a que los partidos
políticos que no pasaron a la segunda
vuelta por un lado y por otro lado
también habrá que ver cuáles son las
posturas que todos estos partidos que no
empresa nación en la vuelta que con
muchísimo
terminamos yendo con respecto a que
tendría que apoyar y en realidad por
ejemplo el exterior se escucha el
candidato guillermo lanzó afirmar que sí
ya que pérez quedaba en la segunda del
time en la portería durante es
posiblemente podríamos suponer que estos
botes de aquí pérez ya se podría
el candidato lazo a partir de una
consideración pero en realidad daba las
dadas las tendencias políticas pero qué
difícil hacer esta afirmación creo que
depende en realidad de cómo mueven las
fichas de candidatos ahora que pasan a
la segunda vuelta y si son capaces de
generar consenso y conciliación con el
resto de partidos porque ciertamente una
de las cuestiones que creo que más
preocupa a partir de los resultados
electorales y la propia contienda con
tanta cantidad debe ver la imposibilidad
que han tenido las diferentes fuerzas
políticas del país desde dar acuerdos de
formar alianzas y creo que esto es un
momento donde efectivamente cualquiera
y cualquier limitación cualquier
discrepancia con usted le tiene que
dejar su lado de cara a generar
ambientes más sólidas que a la postre le
aclaran alta disponibilidad trepidantes
del momento de que tenemos diferencias
sido entre aumentando de número tan
grave el espectro político del ecuador
sino que pero yo que todos los
ciudadanos aspiramos a que el cliente
del condón se cuente si empieza a
trabajar sensibilidad pues quiero
recordarle la audiencia france24 que
estamos en un especial informativo a
propósito de las elecciones generales en
ecuador
hoy los ecuatorianos fueron a las urnas
para elegir presidente y vicepresidente
para el periodo 2021 2025 y además
también a 137 integrantes de la asamblea
y a cinco integrantes del parlamento
andino frente a esta jornada electoral
por supuesto tenemos un equipo
periodístico en quito ecuador- nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega y dos
invitadas analistas que son maría
dolores niños y angélica abajo y albert
con angélica para hacer una pregunta que
vamos a hablar con ambas pero que es
fundamental
de análisis y es el papel del ex
presidente rafael correa y la influencia
política que él todavía tiene en el
ecuador sabemos que correa está en este
momento radicado en bélgica de hace
varios años y que en este momento está
digamos ofreciendo su apoyo al candidato
andrés a araos quien fungió como
ministro durante la presidencia de
rafael correa y se habla del correísmo y
el no correísmo es el término que se ha
aplicado para hablar de quienes apoyan o
no a los candidatos que vienen de la
mano de rafael correa- recordemos que
mismo presidente de lenin moreno en su
momento se presentó como un candidato
del correísmo cosa que después cambió
radicalmente pero angélica cuéntenos
usted cómo analiza esta influencia
todavía a rafael correa que a pesar de
hace unos años vivir fuera del país
todavía está inclinando la balanza de
las fuerzas políticas en ecuador
si la influencia de correa no solamente
a la luz de estar fuera del país sino de
ser un personaje que está condenado
tiene una condena en firme es decir es
una persona que está huida en este
momento de la justicia
su papel ha sido fundamental en la
candidatura de aráoz es decir durante
todo durante toda la campaña de rauch si
no era correa directamente acompañándole
a distintos mítines a través de redes
sociales y demás lo teníamos presente
junto con las imágenes del candidato en
toda la publicidad es decir de alguna
manera la candidatura de graus
representa la elección de rafael correa
en representa
la posibilidad no que ambiciona no
avizoran un porcentaje importante del
electorado de poder volver a aquellos
años de gobierno de rafael correa en ese
sentido todos los que alguna vez y en
ese grupo me incluyo yo dijimos que la
influencia del liderazgo de correa iba a
mejorar a medida que pasa el tiempo y
con la distancia pues se ha visto
completamente refutada no es yo creo en
una de las grandes
una de las grandes variables que
explican
la cantidad de votos que hará vos ha
logrado a abarcar de acuerdo con los
exit polls porque de acuerdo con los
resultados oficiales solamente tenemos
del 2% las dantas actas computadas pero
los exit polls ya le dan a airbus más
menos entre un 34 y un 35 por ciento de
la votación
entonces la influencia de correr está
ahí es importante y es importante
también la digamos como puede todavía
movilizar a un porcentaje muy importante
del electorado luego también desde los
debates entre comillas porque no fueron
debates como tal se vio una
repolarización si se quiere del país de
nuevo entre esa división entre
correístas y anti correístas no era una
línea divisoria que de alguna manera
había quedado oculta detrás de la
pandemia ya había quedado oculta detrás
de los problemas económicos que enfrenta
el país pero que volvió a sumar con
fuerza y de hecho
lo que al final yo creo logra movilizar
a gran parte del electorado a favor de
araus pero al mismo tiempo en los
resultados sobre todos los exit polls se
deja de beber el un porcentaje
importante insisto de entre ya q pérez y
javier hervás el candidato de pachakutik
de la izquierda democrática que dejan
entrever también un porcentaje
importante del electorado que no está va
dispuesto a entrar en el juego en ese
juego de polarización entre correísmo
anti corréis bueno pues este es el
análisis de angélica abad pero yo quiero
ir con maría dolores niño un poquito más
hacia el fondo esta pregunta y es más
allá de la influencia política del ex
presidente correa en estas elecciones y
en lo que ha sido la vida política del
ecuador desde que ya no es desde que
llegó a la presidencia desde que ya no
es presidente que implicaría volver al
modelo económico y político planteado
por rafael correa también no es
solamente la sombra de correa o el
nombre de correa sino la visión política
que corre a la que se está jugando aquí
y la que llevaría a ecuador a retomar
las políticas planteadas por el que por
supuesto
implica desmontar lo implementado por el
mismo a quien acusan de una crisis
económica que también puede ser
relacionada con la pandemia de ccoo y 19
entonces que implicaría volver o no a la
visión planteada de rafael correa para
el país
y yo creo que es importante recordar que
en realidad de moderna rafael correa uno
mercado por varias violaciones de
derechos humanos de expresión entonces
que comience ver con la libertad de
expresión es también todo españa 2 por
varios escándalos relativos a la
incorrecta administración de justicia
seleccionamos en palabras del propio
correr a la entidad de manga y si
entonces estamos frente a la posibilidad
de regresar hacia un gobierno que sea
autoritario que ser desconocedor de las
obligaciones de estatales en materia de
derechos humanos hasta el punto de tener
abiertas confrontaciones con organismos
nacionales de protección de derechos
humanos como por ejemplo la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos y
sobre todo recordemos la relatoría
especial para la libertad de expresión
que en ese tiempo era muy crítica con la
postura hostil del gobierno cora con
respecto a la prepa ahora
en ese tiempo el color está atravesando
por una ganancia económica del que
posiblemente eso permitía quizás de usar
de niveles mayores de ingresos y de
mejor situación digamos laboral y
económica la población también es cierto
pero eso creo yo no era parte de una
política de rafael correa sino de una
situación de coyuntura entonces pensar
por ejemplo que vuelve rafael correa y
hay que decirlo de esta manera porque
candidatura o en realidad no está ahí
por el mismo me por sus méritos en ésta
y en representación y porque cobrando
puede participar en estas elecciones que
hay que tomar en cuenta no no es una
garantía para
las poblaciones que hables de la
explicitación alegadamente de la
telecomunicación y esto sería lo único
respetable porque en realidad como les
digo en materia de derecho de materia de
garantías en materia de tolerancia a la
disidencia en realidad con gobierno que
internacional no te fue conocido por sus
retratos a estos pilares fundamentales
de la democracia
en realidad devolver el correo a través
de lado al gobierno nos estaríamos
enfrentando nuevamente a la posibilidad
de que el ecuador
salga a tener un gobierno utiliza a que
vuelva a tener un gobierno que
capitaliza estas divisiones de
divisiones especiales de económica en la
población de las aguas para generar no
me entiendo bien al sanitario donde no
se respetan derechos humanos y que
además tendrá que transitar en una
situación económica un escenario
económico muy distinto al que se vivió
al inicio de su gobierno en el año
creo que la perspectiva de la vigencia
de la fortaleza de las instituciones
democráticas de la posibilidad de la
función crucial del palabra liberal
independiente imparcial
si hay un río grande si es que el
candidato no replicará la forma hostil e
historia sobre todo de gobernar de
rafael correa y creo que no es nuestro
de menos con la importancia de la
población muy preocupada por regresar a
esta forma de gobernar que era donde
toda la divisoria y sobre todo y respeto
cabe la disidencia del crítica nos
pensábamos distinto
bueno pues en este momento quiero
agradecerle a mis invitados por esta
primera ronda en sus análisis y dar un
vistazo a las cifras en los primeros
momentos del conteo oficial de los votos
vamos a ver entonces cómo avanza la
votación y cómo aparece en los tres
primeros candidatos los que lideran esta
votación tenemos entonces más o menos
escrutado un 0,2 por ciento de la
votación y encabeza los resultados
andrés araus con un 31 88 por ciento
seguido de guillermo lazo con un 18,98
por ciento y finalmente en tercer lugar
ya q pérez con un 20,99 por ciento vemos
que la diferencia no es abismal hay
cierta paridad entre estos tres
candidatos sin embargo por supuesto que
han de zarautz lidera está esta votación
por el momento esto es solamente datos
oficiales pero preliminares en cuanto a
que es un porcentaje muy pequeño que se
ha escrutado como para darle una
victoria alguno de los candidatos
también quiero preguntarle a angélica
boat cuál es la importancia de los
sondeos de boca de urna
en ecuador porque veo que ustedes
mencionan con frecuencia que los
resultados oficiales todavía no han
dicho pero que los sondeos de boca de
urnas y cuéntenos angélica cuál es la
importancia y quién realiza estos
sondeos de bocado en ecuador
bueno los sondeos de boca de urnas son
importantes porque de alguna manera nos
dan información más rápido que el conteo
oficial pero han sido polémicos han sido
polémicos sobre todo porque durante los
10 años del gobierno rafael correa
el conteo digamos de las elecciones de
2010 de 2017 cuando moreno se disputó la
presidencia nuevamente con lazo hubieron
ciertos apagones informáticos que
llevaron a muchos muchos actores
políticos de mucho ya un gran porcentaje
del electorado a pensar que hubo alguna
manipulación de los digamos de los
resultados de la votación
en algunos casos claro eso iba en los
resultados oficiales fueron en contra de
los de exit poll en este caso el consejo
nacional electoral aprobó solamente a
dos empresas para publicar éxitos se
promulgaron a las cinco de la tarde y
sobre los cuales estamos trabajando del
momento y digamos son dos empresas
serias se pensaría que digamos que su
trabajo técnico está bien hecho y que
los resultados se van a aproximar a la
realidad luego el problema en nuestro
país no es tanto los éxitos como las
encuestas de intención de voto
porque de alguna manera se les da
muchísima importancia a los medios de
comunicación ustedes les dan mucha
importancia esos sondeos de intención de
voto- aún cuando las fichas técnicas los
porcentajes de error el grado de
representatividad de esas encuestas no
es de una representación del país y esto
sumado a que existe o se declaraba un
porcentaje bastante grande del
electorado en torno a un 40 por ciento
de las personas que respondían estas
encuestas que todavía decían no haber
decidido por quién votar no entonces de
alguna manera confiamos en los exit
polls pero siempre
digamos considerando de que puede haber
un cierto margen de error luego el día
de la votación los electores suelen ya
ser más honestos cuando responden estas
encuestas y decir directamente con quien
han votado pero de nuevo veremos como
esto realmente después se traduce o se
correlaciona con los resultados
oficiales y yo solamente quería acotar
una patita chiquita a la intervención de
maría dolores en él
en el espacio anterior
digamos un gobierno imposible de arados
nunca va a ser un gobierno parecido al
de correr no solamente por el escenario
económico y todo todo el contexto que
dio sino también creo que es un factor
importante resultados todavía no tenemos
la configuración del legislativo si bien
se perfila un legislativo con una
mayoría afín a rauch de todas maneras la
fragmentación en la asamblea va a ser
muy difícil que el gobierno tenga o
cualquier gobierno que se forme tenga la
cantidad de apoyos suficientes en el
legislativo como para poder sacar
adelante política pública sin necesidad
de ningún tipo de fiscalización que fue
lo que ocurrió durante los 10 años de
gobierno de rafael correa eso es bueno
pues se pienso que una palabra clave de
estas campañas presidenciales y esta
elección fue justamente correa con la
que termina angélica y la siguiente se
la voy a poner una pregunta a maría
dolores y es venezuela
pienso que fueron dos temas clave en la
campaña vimos aia cv pérez por ejemplo
mencionando con frecuencia
el jugador no debía llegar al estado del
que está venezuela ni tener líderes como
los de venezuela digamos que ese tema ha
sido no únicamente utilizado en ecuador
sino en américa latina para las
diferentes campañas y creo que este
mejor análisis maría dolores de como
este tema la crisis venezolana y también
la admiración venezolana que cuado
recibe una buena parte ha afectado o ha
sido puesto como uno de los temas
principales de las campañas
y creo que el tema de mi escuela ha sido
utilizado como una forma de campaña
inclinada sin miedo del electorado un
poco tratando de poner el ejemplo de la
crisis política económica de venezuela a
la hora de persuadir al votante de que
no se vaya por la opción que estaba que
está de hecho políticamente cercana al
gobierno que al demostrar la del
presidente nicolás maduro en realidad
también el tema de la inmigración
venezolana a servir un poco para generar
esta preocupación en el electorado de
hasta qué punto ir por ciertas opciones
electorales y más específicamente el
caso de brown podría llegar a ecuador
progresivamente
estar en la misma situación de crisis
tanto económica como política como
realista denunció el ahora especialmente
en el ámbito económico porque como usted
estado en ecuador desde hace ya varios
años desde un país dolarizado y en
realidad la dolarización ha permitido
que se puedan mantener unos niveles de
vida
aceptables que necesita sobre todo la
inflación la devaluación de la moneda
que ha captado esta crisis de comandar
entonces un valorar el tema del suelo
incluido también el transfondo del temor
de la desdolarización y del impacto
económico que una medida de este tipo
podría causar en el país entonces creo
yo que no tienen temores que es de s la
consecuencia segundo plantearon en
algunas campañas de electoral y de
desdolarizar económico pelé no sería
convertirse en venezuela ni transitar
hacia una crisis económica de iguales
desplazados y peores
ahora con respecto a la migración de
nuestra banda yo creo que muchas veces
no sólo en el contexto de esta de esta
campaña electoral se ha utilizado mal la
existencia y la confluencia de salidas
por ecuador el bloque para atemorizar
también a la población en contra de los
migrantes venezolanos a quienes
desafortunadamente se ha estigmatizado
se ha criminalizado pero que también
sigue siendo la prueba o el vertido del
que existe una situación grave en del
viso la que no quisiéramos aplicar en
otros países
en realidad creo yo que hay es la parte
del electorado que no induce
como su cantidad de elecciones si le
mueve muchísimo el temor de una eventual
crisis económica en general quienes se
expresan preocupación sobre este posible
futuro para el cuadro son personas que
se identifican por ejemplo con el
emprendimiento con la empresa privada
aquellas personas que implican que esta
necesidad de trabajar y la necesidad de
mantener la empresa privada implica como
una fuente de trabajo y de prosperidad
para el ecuador requiere ser protegida a
través de la protección de la
valorización y que entre los planes del
govern hará auditoría una de las medidas
efectivamente hacer este proceso de
desdolarización partidos como un poco
más control del icono entonces si
efectivamente creo que hubo la intención
de que exista temor en los votantes con
escándalo he ha de ser una segunda
objetividad venezuela pero creo que los
resultados del día de hoy parece un kart
que no fue
diciéndole el té fuerte como para
disuadir a los votantes de elegir la
opción arauz que en realidad corre bueno
pues antes de continuar con mis
invitadas para una última ronda de
preguntas vamos a pasar nuevamente al
centro de cómputo en la ciudad de quito
capital ecuatoriana donde está nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega gustavo en
este momento quiero preguntarle ahí en
qué momento justamente vamos a tener
resultados oficiales en qué momento se
hará mañana dentro de cuántas horas se
calcula según el cnt que habrá un
resultado definitivo de esta elección
presidencial
bueno comenzando con el consejero seco
de verano indicaba que luego del cierre
de los centros de votación la normativa
indica que aproximadamente en tres horas
ya se estaba produciendo en este momento
vemos cómo empiezan a generarse los
resultados pero en la mayoría de los
casos todavía nos falta por lo menos 90%
en la mayoría de los casos en todo el
país lo que sí nos dijo incluso ibeas
antes de entrar a este espacio es que
resultados oficiales definitivas podrían
conocerse inclusive para el día de
mañana donde se halla totalizado y hayan
pasado las diferentes impugnaciones que
otorga la ley a las distintas
organizaciones políticas por el cual en
este momento una de las novedades es que
luego de escanear las actas de
electorales las organizaciones políticas
reciben también las actas y deben hacer
las impugnaciones a las que crean lugar
pero también informarte que poco a poco
ya van llegando los distintos consejeros
electorales ya en el de esta área de
totalización pueden verse los distintos
actores sociales representantes de los
partidos políticos los consejeros de el
órgano comicial así que todo hace pensar
que en cualquier momento también podría
conocerse un segundo informe él sólo se
conoce que ya la participación fue
superior al 70% en ecuador lo que había
dicho inclusive uno de los consejeros
durante esta mañana que se esperaba una
buena participación electoral igual
forma informarte también que hace
algunos minutos el presidente de la
república ha dicho que respetará los
resultados electorales sean cuales sean
sobre todo exhortando a respetar la
voluntad popular se conoce que él se
mantiene con su equipo
de gobierno reunido en un hotel de la
ciudad porque también se ha creado este
comité de transición para otorgar así
toda la información de la gestión del
gobierno al próximo candidato es lo que
está pasando en este momento en este
centro de toda la licitación pues
justamente gustado vamos a dar un último
vistazo por este especial informativo a
las cifras a lo que arroja el centro de
cómputo especializado del cn en ecuador
vamos a ver que tenemos ya en un 31 como
41 por ciento para el candidato andrés
arauz quien validando entonces estos
resultados en segundo lugar con un 18 95
por ciento tenemos a guillermo lasso y
con un 20,26 por ciento el candidato ya
q pérez del partido indígena esto con un
5 puntos 78 por ciento de los votos
escrutados y vamos a ir con una última
ronda con nuestras invitadas y yo quiero
ir de inmediato con angélica para
preguntarle angélica brevemente cuénteme
la participación indígena un tercer
candidato indígena y una fuerza indígena
capaz de paralizar el país como lo vimos
en años anteriores
influye en esta elección el pueblo
indígena ecuatoriano que tiene un alto
porcentaje poblacional
bueno yo creo que influye mucho si bien
un ya que pérez no se puede considerar
como un dirigente histórico del
movimiento indígena así que en los
últimos 15 años he configurado o se ha
posicionado sobre todo aquí en el sur en
el austro ecuatoriano como un dirigente
sobre todo la llegada de cuatro nariño
que es una de las opciones
organizaciones adscritas a la conaie en
más que el movimiento indígena yo que es
suele actuar digamos de manera
cohesionada y muy disciplinada y con
apoyos el ya cooper es creo que
capitaliza una serie de demandas
insatisfechas es que la mayor parte de
candidaturas presentes para la elección
presidencial no tomaron para sí los
después de las protestas de octubre de
2019 no en nada en octubre de 2019 vimos
un movimiento indígena refortalecido que
de alguna manera había sido aplicado
durante los 10 años de gobierno de
rafael correa había sido perseguido sus
líderes enjuiciados
vimos ese resurgir y la capacidad
organizativa que tiene el movimiento
indígena en el país y también la
capacidad que tiene el movimiento
indígena de plegar o de digamos o de
aunar otra serie de demandas porque en
octubre había muchos doctores habían
muchas demandas y de alguna manera
la candidatura de jacko pérez y la
defensa por el agua y toda la retórica y
el discurso construido en torno a su
nombre y el nombre de su programa de
gobierno no nunca por la vida y demás yo
creo que viene a visibilizar también una
parte importante de los electores que
están buscando otra cosa que no es
corregir lo que no es la derecha y que
claro son los partidos políticos
bueno pues angélica abbas gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en prado 24 y
antes de finalizar quiero ir con maria
dolores niño para preguntarle por las
mujeres 16 candidatos es solamente una
mujer jimena peña del partido alianza
país como vemos entonces la
participación de las mujeres en la
política ecuatoriana
en realidad lo que creo que es
preocupante que de tantos demonios es
una propuesta de una candidatura
presidencial ilumina lo que evidencia
que esta cualidad de suficiencia de
calidad y de igualdad en cuanto al
ejercicio de los derechos políticos que
está consagrado en nuestra constitución
todavía no pasa de ser simplemente
letras de un texto fundamental
a esto creo yo que tenemos que dirigir
la atención a qué es lo que están
haciendo los dirigencia de los partidos
para efectivamente promover la
participación política de las mujeres lo
cual es sumamente importante porque en
realidad una mujer en una posición de
poder si tiene la posibilidad de
trasladar el mundo al gobierno entonces
las preocupaciones que tenemos las
mujeres que además una gran mayoría de
la población hacia políticas y leyes
encaminadas a garantizar adecuadamente
nuestros derechos mohamed preocupantes
liliana que las 16 candidaturas
solamente exista una
candidatura de una presidenta en una
candidata mujer al presidente y lo que
también es preocupante lo que ha venido
pasando en las candidaturas de la
asamblea donde se ha visto que si bien
hay varias son participando usualmente
estas mujeres no están como principales
mucho listas sino que están de segundas
de alterna de un candidato hombre
principal entonces esto nos lleva a
pensar en realidad que los partidos
muchas veces incluyen candidaturas
mujeres posiblemente para de unas u
otras o para un poco más cuidar la
existencia de esta disparidad de géneros
pero en realidad no existe un compromiso
real desde los diferentes partidos
políticos de darle a la mujer a las
mujeres desde nuestros diversos lugares
no perteneciendo también a diferentes
grupos una voz y la posibilidad real de
llegar a un cargo público donde
efectivamente kodak no que tenga una
diferencia
en la construcción de políticas públicas
que favorezcan a las mujeres y creo que
es una de las grandes decisiones una
bastante decepción no en realidad este
proceso político donde no sólo las
mujeres hemos sido mayormente utilizadas
pero también otras minorías por ejemplo
la comunidad de las poblaciones de hacer
cotidiano por ejemplo a la comunidad gmt
y no tiene ningún tipo de representación
una representación mundo yo creo que no
se compadece con los fundamentos de este
estado de derecho y justicia que
nosotros menos
claro que si ecuador también cuenta con
una amplia población afro ubicada
principalmente la región de asia en la
costa pacífico del país tampoco la vemos
reflejada en estos comicios pues quiero
agradecer entonces a nuestras invitadas
de hoy maría dolores niño abogada
docente de la universidad internacional
de ecuador por estar aquí en france 24
también es directora del observatorio de
derechos y justicia y por otro lado
angélica abad politóloga docente de la
universidad de cuenca ya se han estado
con nosotras para con nosotros y
nosotras principalmente para analizar
estos estos comicios presidenciales y
generales en ecuador también asamblea
seguir eligió durante esta jornada y
también nuestro corresponsal en quitó
gustado ortega con la información desde
el centro de cómputo destinado por el
consejo nacional electoral de ecuador
para ofrecer datos de primera mano en
estos resultados donde esperamos saber
quién ocupará la casa presidencial
palacio de carondelet en ecuador de 2021
a 2025 por ahora finalizamos este
especial informativo mi nombre liliana
valencia ustedes pueden continuar con
más nuestra página web tras 24 punto com
pero antes damos una última mirada a los
resultados vamos a ver que tenemos un
cambio en la posición de los tres
primeros candidatos tenemos a andrés
árabes con un 32 como 46 por ciento y
vemos que ahora el candidato ya q pérez
superó por más o menos dos puntos
porcentuales
a guillermo lasso ya q pérez tiene un 20
como 20 por ciento de la votación hasta
el momento y guillermo lasso un 18,96
por ciento con un 6,93 por ciento de los
votos escrutados
finalizamos este especial informativo de
tras 24 pero ya venimos con noticias
aquí en france 24 quédense con nosotros